نعم مازلت على قيد الحياه حمان الله هذه
المره من امام بيته المقصوف في ضواحي
كراماتسك هذا ما كان يوري يخبر به عائلته
التي كان قد نقلها بعيدا وبقي هو هنا قدر
للصاروخ ان يسقط امام منزله فنجى وهذا جزء
من يوميات العديد من مدن مقاطعه دونيت
وبلداتها مع القصف الروسي لكن النتيجه
تعادتا لا تكون متشابهه
مدنيه بالكامل ولما تخيل ان تصادف لاننا
لسنا على الجبهه اما الذي يجعل مني هدفه
الصحابنا الجيش الاوكراني الى احدى نقاط
المواجهه على جبهه دونيتسك وكل ما اقتربنا
اتضحت اثار المعارك العنيفه التي دارته
هنا
كانت وحده المدفعيه التي يقودها دي مترو
تستعد لتوجيه ضربه لتجمعات الجيش الروسي
بعد ان وصلت احداثيات المكان قال لنا ان
الاسلحه الغربيه الحديثه ساعدتهم على
الصمود رغم شراسه المعارك طوال هذه المده
في وجه الجيش الذي يوصف بانه ثاني اقوى
جيوش العالم
الان يمكننا الانتقال بين المواقع بشكل
اسرع والاصابه بدقه اكثر قبل ذلك كنا
مجموعات اكبر وبطيئه الحركه لذلك كنا هدفا
اسهل لكن ما زال لدينا القليل مقارنه
بالعتاد الروسي
المعارك مستمره على طول خطوط لمواجهه في
اقليم دومباز الا ان محورين بخموت
وافديفكافيدونيت ومحور كريمي نسبهوفا في
لوغانسك تبقى هي الاسخن وهي المحاور التي
ترجح قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان تعززها
روسيا بقوات المظليين الخاصه المنسحبه من
مقاطعه خرسون في الجنوب
مدير الشركه الذي التحق بالجيش وهو في
الخمسين من عمره يبدو ان هذا التطور على
خطورته لا يعني له الكثير
روسيا هي من قررت انضمام للجيش عندما دمرت
منطقه نعم وصلتنا اخبار تعزيزاتهم بالنسبه
الينا ما دمنا نملك ذخائر في مدفعنا
فسستمر في القتال حتى النهايه
اوكرانيا ويبدو ان الوضع متجه نحو مزيد من
التصعيد مع توتر الاخبار عن تعزيزات
الروسيه الكبيره قادمه من الجبهه الجنوبيه